you
hi everyone is Jerry in order for the
fishing pole trap to be successful you
need three key ingredients a hook bait
and a fish that bites in this first
example how the Royal Lopes will see
that the fish turns out to be a pond but
we're not limited to just this opening
as the same concept can be applied to
the Sicilian defense where we'll see
that the fish turns out to be something
else so out of the Royal opaz and more
specifically the Berlin defense with
tonight f6
we have white castling and instead of
going with the main line Knight takes
pawn which is just a temporary pawn when
we go to g4 which is throwing this night
out for bait a typical reaction is to
just try and kick it away with age three
but that Knight need not go anywhere
h5 provides a hook to that night and if
it's taken takes takes this h-file is
peeled open this Knight is hit and if he
runs away let's say Knight to e1 turns
out to be a matin for already at this
very early stage starting first with
Queen h4 two different main threats the
only way to delay may is with f4
preparing to meet a queen check with the
King running away but one patient moved
g3 takes away that escape square and now
the only way to delay mate is to sack
the Queen
but after takes pick your favorite move
as White Queen h1 on the next turn game
over so that's just a quick what if the
knight is taken again the main concept
here being the hook bait and in this
case the pond the fish that ends up
biting now there is one interesting line
that's just way too appealing not to
show now on the white side it's very
typical to maybe get caught up in the
routine out of the road Lopes this right
here being a very common move but it
runs into Bishop c5 converging on f2 and
if white at this point was banking on
this move d4 to work out
there's sadly mistaken because of blacks
continuation Knight takes pawn Knight
takes Knight and not Bishop takes Knight
this is something that white might have
been thinking black would do at this
point if that did come about if Bishop
takes Knight the Queen just grabs the
knight in white as the side is just up a
minor piece but the trick here is to not
immediately take this night instead
Queen h4 which is setting up a beautiful
finish the Queen and Knight are now
converging on h2 and f2 and there's not
a way to really conveniently meet both
threats and not to mention this Knight
is being threatened twice a typical move
to maybe see at this point is to just at
least defend one of these squares and at
the same time throw a punch at the Queen
but it runs into a mate and three and
again one of the most beautiful type of
checkmates to seen a chess game
capturing first on f2 King h1 and now
Queen g1 and pick your favorite way to
take the Queen
it doesn't matter Knight f2 and we have
that aesthetic smothered me so just that
was just a quick sideline out of the
road Lopez and I do want to also touch
on how you can set things up out of the
Sicilian defense
so after c5 Knight f3 d6 d4 we have an
open Sicilian basically these are 2 prep
moves to eventually secure the Queen
position on c7 Bishop e2 these are all
pretty common moves to see black castles
and now this right here is okay already
starting to look for little tricks here
switch to the move order in the road
Lopez it was first a knight here and
then the pond came up but you could also
switch that up and now you can have
Bishop here Bishop to g5 as well and
this is an interesting move to run with
at this point we are threatening made at
this point we're also on this Bishop and
so Bishop takes Knight pawn takes
of course if Queen takes pawn and this
has happened countless times in games
that I've played in Bullitt converging
on h2 for whatever the reason when the
queen and rook are not let's say trained
along just the h-file becomes more
difficult to see that there is actually
a main threat happening on h2 if Queen
takes that's just game over but worst
case scenario should this position come
about is well white is having to defend
mate like this for the most part and
well this pawn is going to fall it's an
interesting final position because
there's cool compensation here what
would we have we have a half-open file
for the rook we have the bishop pair and
with this last move last pawn move for
white that g3 move note that these light
squares are incredibly weakened and
there's certainly compensation in this
final position right here out of the
Sicilian so this is again just a
worst-case scenario black being down
upon but certainly there is compensation
should white not fall for that mate on
the h2 square
you